good morning Hank it's Tuesday I'm in my
basement wearing a tie which can only
mean one thing it's time for the Bank of
nerdfighteria semi-annual report so the
Bank of nerdfighteria is like the US
federal government or an exceptionally
unhealthy tree it has three branches
there's the lending branch the spending
branch and then the giving branch let's
start with the lending branch over at
kiva.org more than 49,000 members of the
nerdfighter keep a group have now won
more than 6.3 million dollars to
entrepreneurs in the developing world
where the second largest group of all
time on the website you can make ones of
as little as $25 to the entrepreneur of
your choice and you have a 99% chance of
getting paid back so it's like a savings
account with a negative 1% interest rate
which is pretty healthy these days there
is even gonna do we do below to learn
more okay under the spending arm so a
car channels crash course and scishow
are both primarily supported not by
advertising but by voluntary
subscriptions at patreon basically
people who value crash course and
scishow and can afford to support them
can go to patreon and do so so that the
rest of us can watch it for free
Haigh lots of people told us that this
would never work but in fact so far it's
working great
both crash course and scishow are now
not only fully sustainable thanks to
patreon but we're hoping to be able to
expand both of them in 2016 so thank you
they're also cool perks if you support
the show on patreon there's a link in
the doobly-doo and lastly the giving arm
so hank the 9th annual project for
awesome starts this Friday at noon
Eastern Time
but the fundraising starts at midnight
tonight with the launch of the IndieGoGo
with lots of amazing perks with 100% of
the proceeds going to benefit the
foundation to decrease worldsuck which
is the real name of our real charity and
yes your donations are tax-deductible
the foundation to decrease worldsuck has
no over net everyone who works on it
volunteers their time all it does is
take money we raised during the project
for awesome and the rest of the year and
distribute it out to charities this year
during the first half of the project for
awesome we're raising money for Save the
Children and the UN's High Commission on
refugees and during that half of the
people write your donations will be
matched Save the Children donors have
put up three hundred fifty thousand
dollars of matching donations and Hank
and I are gonna match another two
hundred fifty thousand so every dollar
you donate for the first half the
project for awesome will be matched and
then in the second half we're going to
be raising money for charities chosen by
you starting on Friday you can go to
projectforawesome.com watch p4a videos
and vote for your favorites so that
nerdfighteria kind of collectively
what charities we support also if you
have a charity that you feel strongly
about you should make a project for
awesome video if you make an awesome
video explaining why a charity that you
care about deserves people's support it
could win lots of money it happens every
year you can find lots of resources
including project for awesome thumbnails
and stuff at project for awesome calm
there's a link in the doobly-doo also
during the project for awesome there is
a 48 hour livestream starring Hank and
myself and many other people from the
YouTube community during that 48 hours
you can always find a link to the live
stream at project for awesome comments
the one time of year when you're likely
to see my kids cover my face and Sharpie
doll and I forgot to mention that before
it even starts the project for awesome
is off to a great start because the
foundation to decrease worldsuck
already has $80,000 most of that is
either from nerd craft area the
nerdfighter minecraft server or from
vlogbrothers ad revenue half of which
goes to sponsor educational projects
online and half of which goes to the
foundation so thank you for watching and
so if that's the status of the Bank of
nerdfighteria I'm very excited for the
project for awesome if you have any
questions you can leave them in comments
I will try to answer them I've been
pointing at my pants a lot in this video
hank you will also see me on friday
because it is my year to make a p4a
video hmmm so to even things out and
bring order to the universe I will see
you on both next Tuesday and next Friday
then we'll return to normal dftba